i'd say i'm getting more money from
crypto bro
right now bitcoin is so high right now i
already uh
got rid of all my bitcoin i got rid
around 36k
because i was like it's overextended
would you buy in it
so when you say 30. i bought it uh
around 18.
[ __ ] 18 words like 18 000
that's like one share but you don't have
to buy a whole share when you buy into
it you can buy like as
as much money into it as you want but
pre-panda would sit at like 13
then the pandemic hit it dropped down to
five but now it's up to like
39 like it just is going crazy yeah
it's literally 18 what did you sell it
at
so i sold that around 34.
yeah yeah just a little bit but i put
like a lot
so i've profited well but i put quite uh
i'd say i i took like half
i'm putting to you know back into my
bank and then i'm kind of just playing
with this other cash that i have
i'm putting it in like ethereum i'm
pulling in like neo
pulling in all these other old coins
because you know
i know that as soon as alt season
happens as soon as bitcoin chills and
relaxes a bit
then all season happens and then that's
when you get your
100x you get your thousand x on certain
coins and then you makes
real guy yeah yeah this [ __ ] guy dude
i'm taking notes over here
yeah dude